now the last few weeks have been
extremely busy from the Iran deal to
Greece's economic meltdown to Donald
Trump saying who gives a about what
he says it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter but but in all the excitement's
you may have missed one piece of news
that got lost in the shuffle
President Obama tonight granting
clemency to 46 nonviolent drug offenders
the most in one day since the 1960s now
that's fantastic
giving nearly four dozen prisoners who'd
made mistakes a second chance at life
it's basically the criminal-justice
version of top chefs Last Chance kitchen
but with the chance to walk free as the
reward rather than the opportunity to
once again disappoint Padma with your
risotto this brings President Obama's
total commutations to 89 and that's just
counting the humans today I have the
awesome responsibility of granting a
presidential pardon to a pair of turkeys
you are hereby pardoned from the
Thanksgiving dinner table may you have a
wonderful joyful life just look at that
turkeys face even he thinks the annual
turkey pardoning is pathetic look at it
oh just kill me this is the worst thing
that happened to me today and you just
deep-fried my cousin presidential
clemency has always been controversial
from George W Bush commuting scooter
Libby's sentence to Bill Clinton
pardoning financier mark rich - and this
is true Abraham Lincoln pardoning a man
convicted of attempted best eality
because the man was intoxicated at the
time the man in question John Wilkes
Booth it's true it's actually not true
but if it had been that would have been
amazing right
it would have been them it would have
been amazing and you can read more stuff
like that in my book stranger than truth
John Oliver's
one favorite history lives but the point
is the president commuting these
people's sentences is a big deal because
they've all been subjected to mandatory
minimum sentencing laws which is our
topic tonight mandatory minimums require
judges to punish certain crimes with a
minimum number of years in prison
regardless of context which is a little
strange because context is important for
instance a shouting the phrase I'm
coming is fine when catching a bus but
not okay when you're already on the bus
so circumstances make a huge difference
that's what I'm trying to say now our
current mandatory minimums were mostly
passed during the tough-on-crime era of
the 1980s and 90s and they're partially
responsible for the explosion of our
prison population since 1980 the prison
population has more than quadrupled to
put that into perspective that means one
out of every 100 adults is locked up
that's true we have two million people
incarcerated if we keep going in this
direction we'll soon have enough to
populate an entire new country with
prisoners and trust me when I say that
is not a good idea
literally the only good thing to come
out of that experiment was Hugh Jackman
and that took a hundred and eighty years
it was worth it but it was a long time
but it but it was worth it it was worth
it but that's two centuries but it was
it was working but mandatory minimums
have had a real human cost meet one
prisoner currently serving time in
Oklahoma my name is Kevin Hart
my name is 2030 93 I went here for
trafficking methamphetamine
uh I start my 14th year in just couple
of months and I will be here until I die
yeah I have life without parole for 3
ounces of methamphetamine he got a life
sentence for 3 ounces of meth that is
insane they're treating him like he's
seasoned 5 Walter White when he's barely
episode 1 Jesse Pinkman most of the
mandatory minimum drug laws on the books
were written in the 80s and 90s when
America was in the grips of a
full-fledged anti drug hysteria it was a
time when you could turn on your TV and
see this this is crack rock cocaine it
isn't glamorous or cool or kid stuff who
the kids doing drugs it turns my stomach
it's it's me this is my future it is if
you don't get also drug you use you lose
there's nothing cool about a fool on
drugs the last one you have to anything
that last one have a clear message to
kids listen if you do drugs all your
favorite cartoon characters will show up
and talk to you is that what you want is
that what you want so to finally
perceive drug Menace Ronald Reagan
passed tough mandatory minimum drug
penalties and he's a successor pushed
for even harsher laws justifying them in
an oval office speech featuring this
spectacular moment this is crack cocaine
seized a few days ago by Drug
Enforcement agents in a park just across
the street from the White House it could
easily have been heroin or PCP it's as
innocent looking as candy and now with
the help of this bags contents I shall
ascend into the cosmos on the wings of a
dragon to a place where Joy's
everlasting and fear is but a memory
do this thing let's do this
tango we're coming
and lock phone sidenote here if you are
wondering why someone was dealing drugs
in front of the White House it later
emerged the administration asked the DEA
to relocate a previously arranged drug
sting to make that line in the
President's speech true
the DEA obligingly agreed to move the
buy a little closer to the White House
the only hang-up was that apparently the
teenage drug dealer didn't know exactly
where the White House was no yeah it's
sad that a teenager got caught up in
that sting but that is an unbeatable
prison yard story oh that's an amazing
breaking and entering anecdote you have
did I ever tell you about the time I
sold crack to the President of the
United States and and this was by no
means just a Republican issue Democrats
in Congress state legislatures and even
Bill Clinton also pushed for these laws
and by early 1994 31 states and DC had
mandatory minimum sentences for drug
offenses the United people from either
side of the aisle faster than playing
the chicken dance at a wedding and
that's that is guaranteed to work every
time this is one your auntie knows Bubba
but but nowadays that bipartisan tide
has very much turned everyone from the
President to Ted Cruz has spoken out
against mandatory minimums and earlier
this year a bipartisan group of
legislators introduced a bill to curb
them with this striking statement let me
just start off with a challenge to the
press and everyone in attendance try to
find a more diverse political group
gathered in one place in the history of
the United States Congress in fact I
challenge you to find any group as
diverse as the eight men standing before
you I cannot think of anyone who is not
represented here I challenge it
you are challenged even people who
helped write those laws at the time have
turned on them take Kevin ring
he was a congressional staffer who
helped push mandatory minimums in the
90s because he believed that they were
an effective deterrent he later went to
prison for fraud and meeting his fellow
inmates somewhat changed his mind most
of these guys made stupid mistakes
without any idea of what the punishment
was they just didn't think they're gonna
get caught so you can you can make the
severity off the charts you can you can
do life sentence for jaywalking it's not
gonna stop it of course it isn't
ridiculously long sentences are not a
great deterrent to crime prison
sentences are a lot like penises if
they're used correctly even a short one
can do the trick is a rumor I have heard
and the truth is the truth is that the
two minimums managing minimums didn't
just not work they ruined lives take the
case of Weldon Angelo's a nonviolent
first-time offender when he was 24 he
sold small amounts of marijuana to an
informant while he happened to have a
gun in his possession and as a result he
received a 55 year mandatory minimum
sentence with no parole he won't get out
until he's 79 for selling something
that's currently legal for recreational
use in four states and whose main side
effect is making episodes of Frazier
slightly funnier oh and he was not the
only one affected by his sentence his
two boys were five and seven
they were just destroyed I mean you
could see the sadness in him all the
time then it's cruel
like I'm not saying he doesn't deserve
anything but he did serve his time and
nothing he's in there long enough like
the minimum should have been like five
years maybe fifty five years is way too
much yeah it is it is way too much and
you know who else thinks that the judge
who sentenced him if he had been a
aircraft hijacker you would have gotten
twenty four years in prison if he'd been
a terrorist he would have gotten 20
years in prison if he was a child rapist
he would have gotten 11 years in prison
and now I'm supposed to give him a fifty
five year sentence I mean that's just
not right so wait if my math is right
here this low-level pot dealer received
the exact same sentence as would an
airplane hijacking child raping
terrorists a person so evil I
legitimately don't know if one has ever
existed and he's not alone many judges
many judges oppose mandatory minimums
because they essentially handle the
sentencing power to prosecutors who can
then use the threat of long mandatory
minimums to convince detent defendants
to take a plea bargain or to cooperate
by providing information and we have all
seen this in action on top shows that
heroin we found in your apartment that
kind of weight you got to take that to
federal court mandatory minimum sentence
you're looking at is ten years see we're
giving you a choice here Jimmy you do
the ten years you helped us on these
homicides we're looking at yeah you know
what don't help us out too quickly
either Jimmy we got 23 minutes left in
this episode so you're gonna want to
reveal that relevant information in a
nice piecemeal fashion
and look drugs have hurt people for sure
but the mandatory minimum sentencing
laws designed to stop them have done way
more harm than good
particularly to certain populations in
2010 nearly three-quarters of federal
drug offenders sentenced under mandatory
minimums or black or Hispanic they
affect minorities the way that hockey
injuries affect white people not not
entirely but disproportionately now now
luckily at the federal level we've
reduced some mandatory minimums and
added safety valve provisions to give
judges discretion in certain cases and
on the local level at least 29 states
have rolled back their mandatory minimum
laws but for the most part those reforms
have not been made retroactive meaning
thousands of people are currently stuck
in prison for crimes that would carry
far shorter sentences if they committed
them just a few years later and that
that's terrible just think about how
annoyed you get when people who get
seated after you at a restaurant get
served and leave before you only in this
case the food is prison food the
restaurant is prison and dinner takes 55
King years and the thing is if we go
back if we go back and fix these
mistakes while we still can
the effect can be transformative look at
Jason Hernandez who were sentenced to
life in prison for dealing drugs
including crack watch him read his
commutation from the president being
known that I Barack Obama president of
the United States of America a
consideration of the
other premises neighbours other good and
sufficient reasons me there are two
moving I do hereby grant listen this hit
application let me tell you just how
moving that is I'm moved by it and I'm
British and we are so repressed that
crying in public is punishable by exile
from the country I'm only here because I
saw the trailer for the notebook in the
theatre he wrote her every day for a
year every day for a year
their first love was act like this love
there are so many people who deserve to
have their cases address here is just
one more Sharonda jones
a first-time nonviolent offender she was
sentenced to life for her very minor
part in a crack cocaine ring she hadn't
8 year old daughter when she went to
prison and has had to watch her grow up
from inside there my dream missus is
show up in her school dummy I nobody
gave me life but I can imagine that
being at her graduation her high school
graduation as his cane imagine me not
being there here's the thing that was
eight years ago and she mixed that
graduation and Sharonda was not on the
president's list of commutations last
week nor incidentally was Weldon
Angelo's and as for Kevin art he
couldn't be on the list because he's in
a state facility so his pardon would
need to come from the governor of
Oklahoma and look there should be a lot
more Pardons and commutations
but if we really want to address this
problem permanently we need States and
the federal government not just to
repeal mandatory minimums going forward
but to also pass laws so that existing
prisoners can apply for retro actively
reduced sentences because almost
everyone has agreed that mandatory
minimum laws were a mistake and we
cannot have a system where people are
continuing to pay for that mistake
and we're perhaps their best chance of
getting out of a prison that they should
no longer be in is somehow finding a
turkey costume and hanging around the
key White House at Thanksgiving
you